[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
l'europe dans la course aux
constellations
le 26 juillet l'opérateur français de
satellites eutelsat a annoncé avoir
signé un protocole d'accord pour
fusionner avec le britannique one web
ouvrant la voie à la naissance d'un
géant européen de l'internet haut débit
depuis l'espace
cette opération confirme l'urgence de se
positionner dans la course aux
constellations
à cette fin les commissions des affaires
européennes et des affaires économiques
ont élaboré ensemble une proposition de
résolution européenne pour soutenir le
déploiement d'une constellation
européenne de satellites en orbite basse
le but de cette proposition d'origine
sénatoriale est d'affirmer la
souveraineté spatiale européenne tout en
accélérant la transition numérique
en effet la constellation satellitaire
annoncé pour 2024 doit permettre de
résorber les zones blanches et de
sécuriser les communications
gouvernementales de l'union européenne
et de ses états membres
elle doit aussi améliorer la résilience
des infrastructures de
télécommunications dans un contexte de
multiplication des conflits armés et des
catastrophes naturelles
il y a urgence car les disponibilités
des fréquences et de l'orbité basse sont
limitées
si nous ne mettons pas maintenant en
oeuvre ce projet nous risquons de
dépendre d'autres puissances spatiales
dans ce contexte les sénateurs appelle à
renforcer les garanties de sécurité et
plaide pour une approche plus stricte de
la préférence européenne pour les
lanceurs et les bases de lancement
il se prononce en outre en faveur d'une
vigilance accrue quant aux conditions
d'éligibilité des entreprises non
européennes qui participeront au projet
enfin au regard de l'importance des
investissements nécessaires les
sénateurs demandent que les fonds
européens dédiés aux projets sur la
période 2021 et 2027 soit pérennisé dans
le prochain cadre financier pluriannuel
pour en savoir plus consultez le
communiqué de presse
[Musique]